president Trump announcing a major move
to investigate the investigators he's
giving Attorney General Bill Barr the
authority to declassify any documents
related to the Russia probe the
president hitting Democrats in
explaining the decision they want to try
and get a do-over of the Buller report
it doesn't work that way
I Declassified I guess potentially
millions of pages of documents I don't
know what it is I have no idea but I
want to be transparent our Attorney
General is in charge let's see what he
finds congressman Adam Schiff ripping
the move saying quote the cover-up has
entered a new and dangerous phase and
also it's on American so Jesse now that
this declassification of millions of
documents has occurred do you think that
these deep States going to fight back
because you have to have worked with a
bunch of different agencies who were
allegedly and well all the scoundrels
involved in the coup attempts are gone
if you think about our anaemic Comey
mccabe Strock page all those gangsters
are now out of there so you can't really
do much about the FBI though true and
I'm sure there's some other bad players
out there but if you declassify
everything you're gonna have access to
raw source documents the FISA
applications in the 302s and this is why
the media is so upset by this because
the first time Donald Trump has
convinced the media to be against
transparency the media does not want to
see secret CIA and FBI documents for the
very first time usually they win
Pulitzer Prize with you know finding
these documents from the Vietnam War til
now now they don't want to see it
because they know they participated in a
witch hunt they know that all their
heroes like Comey have been lying and
like Greg said commis the new a vanetti
they're gonna dump him as soon as the
crosshairs go over his head it's
curtains for this guy you better lawyer
up it's even worse than that because
remember there was two parts to mauler
there's collusion and is obstruction so
if there's no collusion how do you
obstruct no crime
it's that obstruction of justice when
you are making so much
it really is obstruction of injustice
that was my line and although I had it
person I invented I remember the Eureka
moment they can tree but I mean imagine
when you see that Muller knew in March
or June 2017 that there was no collusion
and didn't tell the president so he kept
the investigation going making Trump
crazy so he's making Trump's fire that
one fire that one so why didn't he tell
the president there was no collusion
because he was setting a perjury trap
right for the President of the United
States I think that these documents will
be extremely unsettling for the people
that have been promoting the whole
notion of a totally move the goalposts
they accuse the president of obstruction
when it came to the Moller investigation
and now they're saying well he's
obstructing justice by not complying
with these subpoenas that Jerry Nadler
is issuing to them could you imagine if
this is how they're reacting after the
mole report cleared the president if it
had gone the other way I mean if this is
how they're acting when the president is
cleared imagine if there was something
there damat I mean there would have been
mobs and pitchforks this entire circus
is due to the fact that the media and
the Democrats got their asses handed to
them in 2016 and then again with both
Muller was a repeat of the election and
I'm saying that as somebody who didn't
vote for Trump but grew up went with a
moment he got he was inaugurated ago
he's my president I didn't sit there and
I vote if I think I wrote in myself
Trump became my president and I judged
him on her on deeds and not words and
I've been very happy but we're learning
now the three years didn't matter I mean
or two years didn't matter so there
we're gonna do this to him anyway and
it's I don't think it's about Trump it's
about the it's about our viewers Trump
is merely a proxy for the American
people that the media hates that Trump
represents flyover country not Hollywood
non Manhattan people who just sit there
with their fingers up their noses you
know getting drunk in in their trailer
park that's the way they see it so
Kennedy what is the political benefit
for Democrats here obviously they're
trying to satisfy their base who wants
the president
and peach but the rest of the country
pulling overwhelming shows that they
want everyone to move on and actually
focus on I mean that that's the problem
and and Jesse kind of alluded to this is
the press is going to have to do some
real work here and they're going to have
to sift through these things and figure
out what the worst parts were of these
abuses but how are they gonna spin it
that's a problem you can't spin it
that's why it's harder it's problematic
if this is the structure and the system
that we've got and that has to change
and you know you you have to apply a
much more objective lens to this problem
because right now it's so incredibly
subjective and people feel as though
their opinions are fact right I think
it's I think it's gonna rock the FISA
Court yeah I think it was supposed to be
seen inside the FISA Court enough and
and it's not rightly true I don't think
that the Attorney General should
abstract things conveniently for the
president I think we we should see much
more documentation see how these
applications are rubber-stamped see how
the judges justify some of those
decisions see if there's any
follow-through and if it's not enough
then Congress has to get up off their
booties and do something good Greg I
want to go back to the narrative here
before we go with the media and
Democrats in Congress who are now Adam
Schiff included accusing the president
of using law enforcement as a political
weapon now as a result of declassifying
this information so they're essentially
projecting what they've been doing for
the last two three four years on to the
president for being more trips where are
the only ones that are allowed to
weaponize yet intelligence agencies and
also they're they're also the only
people who can dr. videos the media can
provide misleading editorial but nobody
else can we can do it but you can't
montage who you mean but the thing is
right now I mean there's two things
going on right now there's Trump and
there's brexit and both of them are
telling everybody the same story that
the political class is suffering a
global reverse I'm gonna milk it well
said Steve hi
[Laughter]
it's a global reversal tonight what's a
show called next revolution next
revolution with Steve Hilton